pour l'interroger sur son progrès sur la stratégie de référencement.
Elle a dit qu'auparavant,
cette réunion aurait été très intimidante pour elle,
mais sa mentalité était différente.
Elle a préparé les informations, s'est assise avec le client,
il n'était pas question d'elle, rien de personnel,
il était question du client.
Elle a parcouru les données, les chiffres,
a exposé les tendances et le progrès de sa propre voix, à sa façon,
mais a été directe : « Voici ce que j'ai fait pour vous. »
Le client s'est assis et a pris note, il a dit : « OK. »
En décrivant cette réunion, elle a dit :
« Je ne ressentais pas de peur ou de panique
ou me croyais petite,
c'était ainsi avant.
Au lieu de cela, j'ai dit : « Je maîtrise.
Je sais ce que je fais. J'ai confiance. » »
Être correctement estimé est si important.
Vous entendez dans cette histoire
que les implications vont bien au-delà des finances
et jusqu'au domaine du respect de soi et de la confiance en soi.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai raconté deux histoires, une sur la définition de la valeur
et l'autre sur la communication de la valeur,
ce sont les deux éléments nécessaires à l'atteinte de notre revenu potentiel.
Voilà l'équation.
Si vous êtes dans le public
et que vous n'êtes pas payé ce que vous valez,
j'aimerais vous accueillir dans cette équation.
Imaginez ce que pourrait être la vie,
ce que nous pourrions faire de plus,
ce que nous pourrions donner en retour,
ce que nous pourrions prévoir pour l'avenir,
ce sentiment de validation et de respect
si nous pouvions gagner notre plein potentiel,
réaliser notre valeur.
Personne ne vous paiera ce que vous valez.
On ne vous paiera que ce que l'on pense que vous valez
et vous contrôlez cette pensée.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)